you've heard a lot about President
Biden's fall the other day but don't
miss what's happening here it's not just
the full the media operation and the
implications for the Republic that's
what concerns me now Look anyone could
stumble and fall as a sandbag's full but
when a president does it usually
scrutiny and ridicule follow Trump
couldn't even get a walk down a slick
ramp without facing scorn President
Gerald Ford was probably the most
athletic president ever he played
football in a national championship but
when he missed a step just once Chevy
Chase and SNL sketches forever set The
Narrative of Ford as a bumbling buffoon
so it is curious that when Hillary
Clinton collapsed like an old Armani
pantsuit and was physically dumped into
a van there was no SNL sketch or
ridicule which brings us to the current
president who over the last two years
has done more Pratt Falls than Jerry
Lewis
[Music]
part of the problem is Joe Biden is
suffering from a skiff gate and old age
his doctor has admitted as much but in
an effort to show how vigorous he still
is he affects the skipping routine I
call it the Biden Trot he does it all
the time it mostly conjures up images of
Tim Conway's little old man but watch
closely it's the Biden Trot that got him
into trouble at the Air Force Academy
yesterday
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
why are they cheering
expect the White House staff to put more
guard rails around him than the bathroom
at John fetterman's house every time he
goes out it's going to look like he's in
line for a Disney ride lots of rails
note the president's explanation
he blamed the sandbag that was holding
his prompter but it's the American
people who've been sandbagged by
politicians and media who continue to
ignore the obvious and talk away the
decline
it's the advanced team or whoever's
fault that they put a sandbag in front
of him I I trip in my own house I mean
it's not easy I don't want to have a fog
but if I do I hope I get up as good as
he did it's not some sort of uh ominous
Talisman about his medical condition
president you know appears to be in
pretty good physical condition Bruce
Springsteen took a fall he was uh uh on
his uh back for quite a bit longer than
the president today
the reality is Joe Biden is in physical
and mental decline this has been going
on for years we've chronicled it on this
show this latest tumble is just a
reminder of how dire his condition is
but as the world watches the literal
fall of America's president what is more
concerning are the other ominous Falls
of Joe Biden that the media refuses to
cover tonight he's celebrating his debt
deal
I want to commend Senator speaker
McCarthy it was critical to reach an
agreement and it's very good news for
the American people we're protecting
important priorities from Social
Security to Medicare to Medicaid to
Veterans to our transformational
investments in infrastructure and clean
energy
hooray more debt codifying obscene
levels of spending ushered in during
covet this is not a victory this is
another fall one that will hurt you and
your family for generations and as for
the jobs report the job growth is coming
predominantly from new government or
subsidized jobs which you pay for hooray
more government debt
[Music]
thank you
and that debt is on top of more than a
hundred billion that we keep shoveling
or nearly a hundred billion that we keep
shoveling to Ukraine
and that's a Biden fall that may get us
into World War III fewer reporting on
the recent drone attacks on Moscow and
at the Kremlin now Putin's threatening
the use of nuclear weapons and today the
Biden Administration decided it's the
perfect time to try to kick-start
nuclear arms control negotiations with
Russia and China
[Music]
I haven't even gotten to crime or the
record border incursions but they speak
for themselves still the White House
says Joe Biden is just peachy and put
all that big full stuff right out of
your mind
he got got right back up and continued
continued what he was there to do
he did not uh he there was no need for
the doctor to see him as it was related
to the fall and he's doing fine if a
doctor didn't see him then the White
House is negligent he's 80 years old
that hip could be in splinters this is
nothing more than rank politics and
pride which apparently comes before and
after a fall hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else